Sleep is really important for learning. This is especially true for infants.
There's a particular stage of sleep called rapid eye movement sleep that helps
learning the most. This is when your eyes actually move back and forth really,
really quickly. But Greg, why don't you tell em a little bit about that?
&gt;&gt; Sure Lauren. You know, as it turns out, when babies sleep, they spend about 75%
of their time in rapid eye movement sleep. Adults on the other hand are only
spending about 25% of their time in rapid eye movement sleep. Turns out this is
not a coincidence. Because rapid eye movement sleep and brain growth are
related. Neuroscientists tell us that rapid eye movement sleep in fact
consolidates or makes stronger the neural growth involved in learning. So,
babies' brains, because they're growing more, are spending more time in rapid
eye movement sleep.